大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
今天這一集,
我們把史丹佛平行運算CS149的最後六堂課上完,
講臺上是Kvang Fatahelian和Konil Olukotun兩位老師輪流,
這六堂課才回答同一個問題,
大家搶同一份資料的時候,
除了上鎖,
還能怎麼辦?上一集的結論是,
難的不是分工,
是共用,
這一集我先把答案放在前面,
難的不是自己管好每一步,
是把規矩交出去,
交出去的意思是,
你不再一行一行指揮,
你只說你要什麼,
讓程式語言,
讓晶片替你守著,
可是沒交出去,
你只說你要什麼,
讓程式語言,
讓晶片替你守著,
可是沒交出去,
你只說你要
交出去一次你都得放掉一點自由
我們會看到不用鎖要怎麼辦
看到專門為一種問題設計的程式語言
看到一種叫交易師記憶體的想法
看到為了特定工作打造的硬體
最後再回到記憶體存取
把整門課收起來
第一堂課
Cavern在頭影片上畫了一個十字路口
頭影片上是一個十字路口
四個方向各卡著一臺車
每一臺的車頭都伸進路口中間
Cavern問全班你們同意嗎
這四臺車沒有一臺能往前
黃色那臺要往前
前面那塊路被綠色那臺站著
綠色那臺要往前
它前面被下一臺站著
一圈繞回來
每個人都在等前面那個人
而前面那個人在等自己
這種狀況有一個名字
叫Deadlock
中文叫死結
他要成立需要幾個條件同時發生
一塊地方
一次只能一臺車站著
站著就不肯退
而且大家的等待繞成一個圈
K王說如果路口上只有三臺車
就會有一臺走著動
走掉之後位置空出來
後面的人跟著動
他還放了一張自己拍的照片
一臺公車轉彎轉得太開
對面那臺車也不肯退
兩邊就這樣僵在馬路中間
死結是完全不動
還有兩種毛病更難認出來
因為他們看起來一直在動
第一種叫live lock
中文叫火解
你把剛剛那四臺車想成多能倒車
大家看到卡住了就一起後退
退完又一起往前又卡住
再一起後退
系統基礎上滿滿都是動作
可是沒有一件事真的完成
K-1問大家
生活裡最常見的火解是什麼
就是你走到門口
跟對面的人同時往左又同時往右
兩個人就在那裡讓來讓去
第二種叫starvation
中文叫飢餓
他把路口改成黃車
要讓綠車
綠車一輛接一輛過去
整個系統其實一直在完成工作
只是黃車永遠等不到那個空隙
他說這就像假日塞在半月完
你想轉上一號公路
車流一直不斷
你就一直轉不出去
那要怎麼避開這些事
你會想到上鎖
可是鎖本身是什麼做的
K-BON說
你們用了一整個學題的鎖
我們還沒講過它裡面長什麼樣子
硬體給你一道特別的指令
叫test and set
中文叫測試並設定
它做的事是
去看記憶體裡某一格的值
如果那一格是0
就順手把它改成1
而且看跟改是一口氣做完的
中間差不進別人
有了它
鎖就只是記憶體裡的一個格子
1代表有人拿著
0代表沒人
想上鎖你就一直做這道指令
知道你讀回來的是0
那就表示把它改成1的人是你
鎖在你手上
想解鎖更簡單
把那一格寫回0就好
你看
鎖不是什麼特別的東西
它就是一個大家講好怎麼用的變數
我們要把上一集的影印本接回來
鎖是一個變數
變數會被放進快取
也就是每個核心手上都會有一份影印本
三個核心同時想拿鎖
他們就一直做那道測試並設定
而那道指令算一次寫入
沒寫一次其他人手上的影印本就要作廢
所以那一頁在三個核心之間來回飛
而真正拿著鎖的那個人
等到要解鎖的時候
還得排隊把那一頁搶回來
才寫得出那個零
Kevin說得很白
處理器一號
拿著鎖的時間是一整張投影片
可是他手上有那一頁的時間
只有上鎖跟解鎖的兩瞬間
有一個小改法很有效
你先只用讀的
一直看那一格是不是零
不會讓別人作廢
大家安安靜靜的各看各的影印本
看到零了
再衝進去做那道指令
不過這把鎖還是不公平
鎖一放開
所有人同時衝進去搶
運氣不好你可能一直被插隊
蔣介石說怎麼做
K-1換一個問題
鎖要放在哪裡
他放上一個連接串列
也就是一串
前後用箭頭串起來的節點
有人插入有人刪除
沒有鎖的時候
兩個人同時插在相鄰的位置後
做的那個
會把前一個人的插入蓋掉
整段名單就少了一個人
最簡單的修法是整條串列一把大鎖
正確
可是所有人都在排隊
那你當初開這麼多執行區要做什麼
於是臺下說
每一個節點各給一把小鎖
可是順序呢
K-1放了一張美國體能節目的照片
一個人在吊環上前進
你猜他怎麼過去的
他永遠至少抓著一根桿子
放掉一根之前先抓住下一根
走串列也是這樣
你手上隨時鎖著現在這一格和前一格
這個做法叫Hand over Hand
中文可以叫接力式上鎖
接力式上鎖是對的
可是你想想成本
原本走一格只是順著箭頭跳過去
現在每走一格都要上一次鎖
再放一次鎖
K-1說很可能整條一把大鎖還比較快
只能時機量過才知道
所以最後他丟出另一條路
完全不上鎖
硬體有一道指令叫compare and swap
中文叫比較並交換
他做的事是
你告訴他三件事位置在哪
你以為那裡是多少
你想寫進去多少
如果那裡真的還是你以為的那個值
他就替你寫進去
如果被別人動過了
他什麼都不做
只回頭告訴你現在是多少
你有沒有覺得這個很眼熟
你和同事同時再改一份共用文件
你打完一段暗儲存系統跳出來說
這份文件在你編輯的時候有人改過
鎖的想法是我進去的時候
別人都不準動
不上鎖的想法是大家都先做
最後一刻才檢查
撞到了就重做一次
下一堂課
Kvon要講的是一整類程式語言
他先在黑板上畫了三個願望
第一
好寫
你想到什麼就寫得出來
第二
跑得快
第三
什麼程式都能寫
他說
幾十年來大家都在找
同時做到三件事的語言
找不到
你用Python好寫
什麼都能寫
可是不快
你用C或CUDA
快
什麼都能寫
可是難寫
所以有一群人決定放掉第三個願望
這種語言叫Domain Specific Language
中文叫領域專用語言
它只讓你寫某一類程式
替你安排的特別好
你其實天天都在用
你在資料庫下一句SUL
說我要哪些資料
你從來不會去想
它怎麼在幾十臺機器上平行跑
這就像瑞士刀跟開屏器
瑞士刀什麼都能做
開屏器只為一件事
可是開屏那一下
開屏器快得多
這種語言長什麼樣子
KMO拿了一個他自己領域的例子
一個叫Highlight的語言
你可能沒聽過它
可是你很可能天天在用它
他說
如果你用Android手機拍照
你就在跑Highlight寫出來的程式
幾年前你上傳到Instagram的照片
只要經過濾鏡也是highlight在跑
他要解的問題是影像處理
Kvon先放了一段
用手寫的向量指令寫出來的程式
問全班
30秒內告訴我他在做什麼
沒有人看得出來
然後他放上同一件事的普通寫法
點擊幾行
全班馬上打出來
這是把照片變模糊
變模糊
就是每個點換成他跟
周圍八個點的平均
九個數字加起來再平分
同一件事
一個版本看不懂
一個版本看得懂
差別在於看得懂的那個版本慢
那要怎麼讓他快
第一招是少算一點
把照片變模糊這件事
可以分成兩趟做
先橫著平均三個點
再直著平均三個點
答案一模一樣
每個點的乘法從九次掉到六次
如果不是三乘三是七乘七
那就是四十九次掉到十十次
差距很大
可是可以幫我問
這樣有沒有付出什麼
有
你多了一張跟原圖一樣大的暫存
一張手機照片就多吃掉幾十MB的記憶體
而且每個點要多寫一次
多讀一次
又回到上集那句話
你省了算
卻多搬了一趟
那麼
只算一小塊
你一次只做16行的輸出
那就只先算18行的暫存
這一小塊剛好放得盡快取
用源就丟
邊接上會重複算一點點
換算下來每個點
大約6.44乘法
比原本的9次少
暫存也小得多
問題是剛剛那一連串的取捨
你要試多久
K1說
就算你修過這門課
你也不知道哪一種
安排在你這臺機器上最快
你只能一直改一直量
那段從一次一行改成一次一塊的程式
如果自己動手寫
熟練的人也要一個下午
所以黑帶做了一件很少見的事
他把程式分成兩張紙
第一張紙寫演算法
也就是模糊到底是什麼
你就寫每個點
是周圍9個點的平均
跟數學課本上長得一樣
第二張紙寫安排
英文叫Segil
中文就叫排成
你在上面說
請你一次做256乘32的一塊
這一層
請你用8寬的向量指令
一層請你開歐洲新星
最關鍵的一點是
你怎麼改第二張紙
答案永遠不會變
變的只有粗度
想試另一種切法
你改兩個數字就好
這樣就沒問題了嗎
沒有
Kabun講了一個很現實的細節
Highlight後來變成
Google相機的編譯器
公司裡大概有80個人會寫第一張紙
會寫第二張紙
也就是會安排的人只有三個
有一次其中一個人請語音架
那整支就幾乎沒有人在寫排程了
你可以想像那個畫面
一家公司的照片品質
掛在三個人身上
可是這件事後來有了一個很漂亮的轉折
排程雖然難
他的選擇是很規矩的
說穿了就是迴圈怎麼排
哪一段塞進哪一段裡面
這種規矩的選擇
電腦最會找
所以有人把下棋用的搜尋方法搬過來
讓程式自己去試
他們請Google
那兩個世界上最會寫排程的人
現場比
人花了一個小時慢慢調
電腦花一毫秒膠捲
三題裡面電腦贏了兩題
同一堂課還有另一個例子
更能看出交出去的好處
史丹佛做過一個研究用的語言
叫LIST
用它的人是要模擬
噴射引擎的機械吸血神
這種模擬
把物體切成一張網格
上面有很多個點跟很多條邊
程式要對每一條邊算一次
再把結果加回兩端的點上
麻煩在這裡
一個點會被好幾條邊碰到
所以好幾個人要同時寫同一個點
這就是上一集講的搶同一份資料
一般的做法是上鎖
或者用一道一口氣做完的指令
可是在顯示卡上這樣做很慢
Iris的做法是
先把哪些邊會碰到同一個點整理出來
然後替每條邊上色
規定碰到同一個點的邊不能同色
跑的時候就一個顏色一批
同一批裡沒有任何兩條邊會碰到同一個點
完全不用鎖
寫程式的機械繫學生什麼都不用
講臺換人
接下來兩堂課是
空流路口吞
他一上來就把前面那個難題講清楚
你手上有一份大家都要動的資料
你可以在整份外面上一把鎖
好寫 不會錯
可是一次只有一個人進得去
你也可以切細一點
一隔一把鎖
很多人可以同時做
可是你剛剛也看到了
順序一錯就是死結
所以寫程式的人們夾在中間
要正確 還是要快
康口放了一張實測
同一個資料結構
細鎖的版本在一個核心上跑
反而比出鎖慢一大截
因為光是上鎖解鎖就花掉很多時間
要等到四個核心以上細鎖才開始划算
他問
有沒有第三條路
其實有 而且你已經用過它了
你跟同事一起改一份公用文件的時候
你並沒有先跟大家說我要鎖
Countall的例子很生活
我要把錢存進你的賬戶
程式要做三件事
先讀出你現在的餘額
加上我存的錢再寫回去
要是在讀完和寫回去之間
有別人也匯錢給你
你就少了一筆
傳統做法是在這三件事前後
各上一把鎖
另一種寫法是
你在這三行外面寫一個字
Atomic
中文叫不可分割
你沒有講任何一把鎖
你只是宣告
這三行請當成一件事
這兩種寫法的差別
Countall講得很重
宣告不可分割
是在說你要什麼
至於底下要不要用鎖
用幾把
什麼時候放
那是系統的事
這種說要什麼的寫法
你已經見過
你在ISPC裡寫一個voice
也沒有說要開幾條執行序
這整套想法有一個名字
叫Transactional Memory
中文叫交易式記憶體
那一件事到底是什麼意思
康克爾給了三個性質
第一個叫原子性
意思是全有或全無
這一段裡面
所有的讀和寫
要嘛全部算數
要嘛就當作從來沒發生過
第二個叫隔離性
意思是在這一段做完之前
你改的東西別人一個字都看不到
第三個叫可序列化
意思是所有人的這些段落
最後可以排成一條隊
誰先誰後由系統決定
可是一定排得出來
你把這三件事放在一起
其實就是一份共用文件的理想狀況
你的整段修改要碼完整出現
要嘛 明確沒出現
別人不會看到你打到一半的句子
而且所有人的修改排得出先後
學過資料庫的人聽到這裡會覺得熟悉
因為交易這個詞就是從資料庫借來的
只是資料庫還多一個性質
論點也不會丟 記憶體做不到
所以這裡少了那一項
還有一個好處
他其實跑得比你想的快
康克爾畫了一棵樹
兩個人分別要改樹上的兩個節點
一個在左邊 一個在右邊
如果用接力式上鎖
兩個人都得從樹根往下走
而樹根跟第二層是共用的
所以後面那個人只能等
可是你退一步看
這兩個人真正動到的東西完全不一樣
所以系統只要記兩件事
這一段裡你讀過哪些位置
你寫過哪些位置
兩個人的讀和寫如果沒有交集
讓他們同時做 誰也不用等
有交集才排隊
康克爾說這就是交易式記憶體最迷人的地方
你用的是跟出鎖一樣好寫的寫法
拿到的卻是細鎖那種速度
因為他不是看你鎖了什麼
是看你真的碰到了什麼
你再想一次那份公用文件
兩個人改不同段落
本來就不需要互相等
還有一個好處
跟寫程式的方式有關
軟體是一塊一塊拼起來的
你寫好一個提款
寫好一個存款
你希望轉帳
就是把這兩個湊在一起
康口說
鎖在這裡會壞掉
轉帳要先鎖住第一個帳戶
再鎖住第二個帳戶
現在有兩筆轉帳同時發生
方向剛好相反
第一個人鎖住了甲
第二個人鎖住了乙
然後兩個人都在等對方
又是死結
你當然有辦法救
全公司講好
所有的索醫律照
編號有小到大拿
可是你發現問題了嗎
為了把兩個小東西湊在一起
你得先知道整個系統的規矩
那這兩塊就不是各自獨立的積木了
換成交易式記憶體
你在轉賬外面再寫一個不可分割
裡面那兩個自然被包進來
順帶一提
出事的時候你只要說一聲放棄
系統就把這一段做過的修改
整個收回去
不像用鎖
你得記得把每一把都放掉
不過空調也提醒
這個字不是萬靈丹
你包錯地方一樣會出事
他放了一段程式
一邊把一個旗標設成成立
另一邊寫一個迴圈
一直等那個旗標變成立
才往下走
用鎖的寫法
這段程式跑得動
可是你把兩邊都包成不可分割
全班一起發現
它會永遠卡在那裡
為什麼
因為隔離性
隔離的意思就是
這一段做完之前
你改的東西別人看不見
等在迴圈裡的那一邊
就永遠等不到旗標變成立
誰也走不出去
這種錯誤有個名字
叫原子性違規
意思是你把不可分割這四個字
圈在了錯的一段程式外面
你交出去的是怎麼做
不是要做什麼
要做什麼還是你的責任
第二堂交易是記憶體
conto
要講怎麼把它做出來
第一個要決定的事是
你這段做的修改先放在哪裡
第一種叫eager versioning
這種叫積極版本管理
你直接把新的值寫進記憶體
可是在旁邊另外留一份記錄
寫的這一格原本是多少
這份記錄叫undo log
中文叫復原記錄
做完了
把復原記錄丟掉就好
中途放棄
就照著記錄一格一格改回去
第二種叫lazy versioning
中文叫延後版本管理
你不去動記憶體
新的只先寫在自己的一張便條上
這張便條叫寫入緩衝區
做完了
才把便條上的東西一次抄進記憶體
中途放棄
把便條揉掉就好
兩種各有各的痛
積極的做完很快
放棄很慢
延後的放棄很快
做完要抄一輪
而且你讀資料的時候
得多看一個地方
第二個要決定的事是
什麼時候檢查有沒有撞到別人
第一種叫悲觀偵測
他假設一定會撞到
所以每一次讀
每一次寫
都當場檢查一遍
好處是發現得早
發現得早就多一個選擇
你可以先停下來
等對方做完
手上已經做過的東西都還留著
不用重來
壞處是兩邊可能互相讓
你停下來等我
我停下來等你
結果誰都沒有往前
又是前面講過的活節
第二種叫樂觀偵測
他假設不會撞到
一路做到最後
要交出去的時候
才檢查一遍
規矩很簡單
正在交出去的那一個一定贏
其他有讀到同一個位置的
通通放棄重來
它的好處是一定有人往前走
不會整個卡住
壞處是你可能已經白做了一大段
才發現自己早就沒救了
知道要做哪些決定之後
我們先看軟體怎麼做
純軟體的版本
編譯機會把你的程式整個改寫一遍
你每讀一個值
它就替你插一段程式
先去查這個位置有沒有被別人鎖住
版本對不對
然後把它寄進讀過的清單
你沒寫一個值
它又插一段
去拿鎖記賬留下復原記錄
這些多出來的動作有個名字叫軟體屏障
你可以想成每搬一箱東西都要先填一張單子
代價有多大
Canto給的數字很老實
沒有最佳化的版本
在一個核心上就要多花七成到八成的時間
後來Intel的團隊發現
這些單子很多是重複的
交給編譯器整理掉
多花的時間降到三成到四成
這還是在一個核心上
你要的是多核心跑起來會變快
可是門檻就是這麼高
那硬體能不能幫忙
Canto說了一句我很喜歡的話
其實你已經有一套現成的東西了
你回想上一集
好幾個核心手上有同一頁的影印本
誰要改就得先喊一聲
別人就把自己那份作廢
這套規矩叫快取一致性
他在做的事
跟交易師記憶體要的是
幾乎一樣
都是盯著誰碰了同一份資料
所以硬體版的做法很省
每一行快取本來就有幾個狀態位元
現在再多加兩個
一個叫R
記著這一行
我在這一段裡讀過
一個叫W
記著這一行
我在這一段裡寫過
寫過的新值就先留在自己的快取裡
不送出去
這樣別人自然看不到
要放棄的時候把這些位元清掉
那些值也跟著沒了
有了那兩個位元
偵測衝突就變得很直接
你的快取一直在聽線上有沒有人喊話
如果有人喊我要改某一行
你手上那行的讀取位元是亮的
那就代表你這段讀過它
你們撞上了
如果有人喊我要讀某一行
你那行的寫入源是亮的
也一樣
那交出去又是怎麼一回事
就是把你這段寫過的每一行
用原本那套喊話的方式喊出去
我要改這些
別人聽到了發現自己讀過
就得放棄重來
你有沒有發現
這整套就是上一集那套規矩
只是從一行一行變成一整段一起喊
所以Kongro說
你只要懂了
快取一字信
再往前看
交易式記憶體
就只是一小步
聽起來這麼好
你現在電腦有嗎
Conto的答案很誠實
幾乎沒有
Intel真的在處理器裡
做過硬體交易式記憶體
最後沒有走下去
原因有幾成
一個是配套的軟體沒跟上
另一個是它太容易放棄
你這一段的資料
只要被擠出快取
整段就得重來
真正讓它被收起來的
是有人用它挖出了安全漏洞
所以今天你去看Intel的指令手冊
那些指令的定義還寫在裡面
可是新的處理器上沒有做
今天用到交易式記憶體的
多半是軟體版
而且只用在局部
例如資料庫系統裡面
最難用鎖寫對的那幾塊
有學生問以後硬體會做得起來嗎
康頭笑著說
這是個好問題
答案還沒出來
這也提醒我們一件事
一個想法在課堂上很漂亮
不代表它在市場上活得下來
最後兩堂課
第一堂還是空流
他要講的是特化
也就是為了一種工作特別打造的硬體
為什麼需要它
先講一段歷史
以前晶片每換一代
電競體變多
而且每一顆用的電變少
所以你什麼都不用做
速度就自己上去
這個好日子大約在十幾年前結束了
現在電競體還是變多
可是每一顆用的電不再跟著降
你的筆電有個能散掉的熱量上限
資料中心有電費上限
你的手機沒有風扇
連散熱都只能靠機殼慢慢散
所以今天的情況變成這樣
你能用的電是固定的
要更快
只剩一條路
讓每一次運算用掉的電更少
這句話換個方式說
效能問題已經變成能源問題
而省電的辦法只有一個
少做那些跟計算無關的事
那跟計算無關的事有多少
Conto放了一張圓餅圖
把一道乘加指令用掉的電切開來看
真正拿去做那一次乘法和加法的
只佔6%
剩下的9成多花在哪
讀出這道指令
看懂他要做什麼
檢查他有沒有在等前面的結果
確認要用的單元空不空
找出資料在哪個佔存器
把資料搬過來
再把結果搬回去
還有整顆晶片的時脈訊號
你可以想像一間工廠
真正在鎖螺絲的那幾秒
只佔很小一塊
其他時間都在看單字
找工具 搬料
這就是為什麼一般的處理器
在能源上這麼吃虧
他為了什麼城市都能跑
每一道指令都要重新問一次
我現在到底要做什麼
只要電話在哪
省電的方向就清楚了
第一步你已經學過
SIMD
也就是一道指令
一次做很多筆資料
指令看懂指令
那些成本只付一次
卻貪給很多次計算
圓餅圖上灰色的那一塊
就被貪飽了
比較如果一個演算法重要到
值得你為它做一顆專門的晶片
這種晶片叫ASIC
中文叫特定應用機體電路
同樣大的面積
它能算的量大約是一般處理器的1000倍
你想拿來把瑞士刀
一般的處理器什麼都能做
所以每一件事都要先問一次要做什麼
開屏器不用問
它生下來就只會做那一件事
代價也很清楚
那顆晶片只能做那一件事
而且你要等大概18個月才拿得到
你有一個新想法
你等得起
一邊是什麼都能跑
但很耗電的處理器
一邊是省電很多
但只會一招的晶片
中間當然有東西
Ctrl 把它們排成一條線
往右一格是顯示卡
你得學會寫 CUDA
再往右是數位訊號處理器
它的指令是為了訊號處理設計的
複雜到編譯器幾乎寫不出來
你常常得手寫組合語言
再往右是為某一個領域做的晶片
例如 Google
為了機器學習做的 TPU
它做的事說穿了就是
把很大的矩陣乘法算得特別快
你用 Tensorflow 或 PyTorch 就能用到它
再往右是 FGA
一種可以重新接線的晶片
到這裡你等於要當硬體工程師了
最右邊才是剛剛那顆專用晶片
這條線上沒有正確答案
只有取捨
你往右走一格
省下的電是真的要付出的力氣也是真的
那要怎麼做
一顆專用的硬體
以前你只能寫Verilog這種硬體描述語言
很折騰
Conco的實驗室做了另一條路一個叫Special的語言
中文可以叫空間語言
他的想法是
會做這種硬體的人其實已經懂
平行跟資料擺放了
那就讓他直接用這兩件事來描述硬體
在一般的處理器上
資料什麼時候從記憶體進快取
你管不到
在Special裡
你自己說話
這塊記憶體放在晶片上
那塊放在晶片外
什麼時候搬
一次搬多大一塊
好像有用一個很日常的例子
解釋為什麼要一次搬一大塊
你去一趟超市
不會只買一顆蛋
你既然出門了
就一次買一整袋
回來放進冰箱
晶片去一趟
外面的記憶體也是這樣
去一趟很花時間
所以一次拿一整塊回來
Special還有一招
正好街上終極講過的事
你還記得注意力那一層嗎
張一億格的大表不存下來
一塊一塊算完就走
那個做法叫融合
寫起來很不容易
你得自己把好幾個步驟
揉成一段程式
Special換了一個角度
它讓你寫兩段程式
一段算指數
一段把每一橫排加起來
然後在兩段中間
結一條管子
英文叫FIFO
中文就是先進先出
先放進去的先被拿走
這兩段是同時在跑的
前面一段算出一個
就丟進管子
後面一段從管子裡
拿一個就用掉
那張大表根本沒有機會存在
康克說這種寫法
在硬體裡非常自然
在軟體裡反而很難想
因為軟體習慣一段做完才換下一段
最後一堂課回到Kevin
他說整個學期大家一直在喊
記憶體頻寬不夠
可是我們從來沒看過
記憶體裡面長什麼樣子
你的電腦裡那幾條記憶體
上面的晶片叫DRAM
一顆電源晶片裡面是一大片格子
每一格存一個位元
存的方式是一小袋電荷
多一點算1少一點算0
你要讀其中一格
不是伸手去拿那一格
第一步先把一組線的電壓準備好
這一步大約10奈秒
第二步把你要的那一整列的電荷
導到線上
整列搬到晶片底下一個叫列環衝區的地方
這一步又大約10奈秒
第三步
才從那一列裡挑出你要的那幾格送到外面去
你可以想成去檔案室挑資料
管理員不會只抽一張紙給你
他把整個抽屜抬到櫃檯上
抽屜抬上來之後
有一件很實際的事發生了
你要的下一個位元組
如果就在同一列裡
那不用重來
直接從櫃檯上挑就好
快得多
可是如果他在另一列
你得先把櫃檯上這一列寫回去
因為剛剛那個倒的動作
會把原來那一列清空
然後再重新準備一次線
再抬一次抽屜
可以問說
所以記憶體的存取時間
根本不是固定的
同樣是沒有命中快取
你的存取順序長什麼樣子
決定了
你拿到資料要多久
差別有多大
一路順順的拿
跟每次都要重來的
頻寬可能差三到四倍
你在這門課裡
一直被要求連續存取
理由不只是用滿一整行快取
還有這一層
連續的請求
讓記憶體可以一直從
同一個抽屜裡拿
只要慢在哪
接下來的解法你已經很熟了
第一招
一次多拿一點
晶片支援一次
要一整串連續的會員組
一次的準備成本
就攤給很多筆資料
這也是為什麼
一行快取是64個會員組
而線一次只送得了8個
第二招
你一定猜得到
做成流水線
他們把一顆晶片裡的格子
分成好幾區
每一區叫一個bank
中文叫記憶體區塊
當第一區正在把資料送出去的時候
第二區已經在準備線了
第三區在抬抽屜
這樣那組往外送資料的線
只要沒有讓他一直有資料在跑
你就在浪費你最缺的資源
這兩招你在前面兩集都見過
只是這次他們發生在記憶體裡面
這裡有一個細節
我覺得是這一集主線最好的例子
你的程式沒有命中快取
就會送出一個請求
這些請求會先進到一個叫記憶體控制器的地方
他不會照你送來的順序做
他會把一堆請求先收著
然後重新排過
把要到同一個抽屜的請求湊在一起
一次做完
Kevin說NVIDIA顯示卡上的記憶體控制器
可能是整顆晶片最複雜的一塊
他可以壓著上萬筆請求
就為了排出一個對記憶體最友善的順序
而這件事你完全管不到
你在城市裡沒有任何一個指令可以指揮它
還有一個很現實的地方
同一臺機器上還有別的城市在跑
你以為自己的資料排得很漂亮
另一支城市的請求插進來
兩邊就互相打斷
你能做的只有一件事
把你的存取寫得夠連續
讓它好排
還有條路跟排順序無關
是把記憶體整個搬到處理器旁邊
為什麼線只有八條
因為那些線要走過整片主機板很貴
那如果記憶體不放在主機板上
直接放在同一塊硅上呢?
今天高階的顯示卡就是這樣做的
一堆3M晶片疊起來
穿過每一層打通垂直的線
然後透過一小片硅直接接到處理器
原本只能從晶片邊緣拉出去的線
現在可以從整片面積上拉出去
這種記憶體叫HBM
中文叫高頻寬記憶體
線的寬度從64個位元
變成4000多個位元
2016年就能做到每秒720GB
今天更高
K房順手提了一句
中甲獎的那個注意力最佳話
當初的設計目標就是
就是把中間結果放進這一層裡面
不要掉到外面的記憶體去
最後一天
Kevin把整門課收成幾句話
第一句他說
如果今天你只帶走一件事
那就是這句
把事情分給很多人做
其實常常是最簡單的一步
難的是怎麼把資料送到那些處理器手上
從第一堂課那樣子條
到今天的抽屜跟疊起來的記憶體
整門課一直在講同一件事
第二句他講得很坦白
大部分軟體比機器真正做得到慢很多
他說第一份作業就看到了
一支寫得不錯的C程式
比一支真正用上向量指令的程式慢了大約40倍
再加上特化的硬體又是10倍到100倍
所以他提醒大家
以後在實驗室裡
有人說我們要租一整排機器
你先停一下想想
也許花一點力氣改寫就快上1000倍
我們回到開場那句話
這一集
你看到鎖其實只是記憶體裡的一個格子
看到四臺車在路口誰也退不了
看到有人乾脆不上鎖
先做完
最後一刻才檢查
你看到這種語言逼你放掉自由
換他替你安排迴圈
看到一個字寫在程式外面
就把什麼守規矩這件事
整個交給系統
看到一顆位的一件事
打造的晶片
同樣的面積
能算的量是1000倍
最後你看到
連你的請求
要用什麼順序
送進記憶體
都有人替你重排
所以這一集的答案是
男的不是自己管好每一步
是把規矩交出去
而沒交出去一次
你都放掉了一點自由
三集走到這裡
其實是同一條線
上集講的是那張
走過教室的紙條
男的不是算
是搬
中甲講的是
四個人手上的影印本
男的不是分工
是共用
這一集講的是
你願意把多少事交給機器替你守
最後問你一個問題
如果你手上有一件很重要的事
你會自己盯緊每一步
還是把規矩講清楚以後交出去
留言跟我分享
喜歡這種把公開課講清楚的內容
也可以訂閱AI Notebook
我是Jim
我們下次見